الى ايران واكد مصدر ايراني المطلع
للجزيره التوصل لتفاهم جديد مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان احد المواقع
التي تشهد تحقيقا حول وجود جزيئات
اليورانيوم اضاف المصدر الايراني ان تسويه
مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه هي بشان
موقع
مريوان ووجود جزيئات يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه
83.7 اكد المصدر ان الطيران وفقط في مارس
اذار الماضي على اعاده نصب عدد من كاميرات
المراقبه في احدى منشاتها النوويه ولكن
على الا يتم ارسال معلوماتها للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بل يجري تخزينها في
شرائح خاصه
ضموا الينا من طه مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
نور احطنا علما اكثر بموضوع هذا الاتفاق
او التفاهم الجديد بين الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
وطهران وتاثيراته
نعم سلمى الموضوع هو موضوع مفاوضات جاريه
ما بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه منذ ما يقارب ثلاثه اشهر هنا سلمى
يجب ان نضع المساله في سياقها الاساسي في
الاجتماع الاخير لحكام الوكاله كان هناك
توجيه تحذير لايران من قبل الاجتماع وبيان
صادر على الاجتماع بانه على ايران ان
تتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه من اجل ايجاد
حل واجابات لمجموعه من الاشكالات العالقه
ما بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه يرتبط الموضوع بثلاث مواقع نوويه
قالت ايران ان هناك انشطه نوويه
حصلت عليها لم تعلن عنها ايران هناك مساله
الحصول على جزيئات من اليورانيوم المخصب
بنسبه 84% وكذلك تجديد رقابه الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه على ايران والتي
انخفضت بعد من سحبت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من الاتفاق النووي وخفضت ايران
خطواتها النوويه كان هناك لقاء في طهران
بحضور كروسي رئيس مدير المنظمه الدولي
للطاقه الذريه والذي تم الاتفاق عليه على
حرحله هذه المواضيع الان السياق الجديد
اننا على بعد ايام هناك اجتماع جديد لحكام
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وبالتحديد
في الاسبوع الاول من الحزيران بالتاكيد
هناك تقرير للوكاله ربما قد يصدر خلال هذه
الايام الان ظهور هذه المعلومات التي
سربتها الوكاله الدوليه التقنيه الايرانيه
هنا في طهران ربما هو رساله على ان شيئا
ما حدث في الاتفاق وتم تجاوز بعض العقبات
العقبات التي يتم الحديث عنها انه تم
تجاوزها لحد الساعه هناك الانشطه النوويه
التي كانت تقول الوكاله الدوليه انها كانت
في موقع ماريفان او ما كانوا يعرف يقول
تقول الوكاله الدولي للمنظمه الايرانيه
بانها اجابت عن هذه الاسئله وان هذا
الاشكال تم رفعه بالحوار ما بين مفتشي
الوكاله الدولي للتريه والمسؤولين
الايرانيين كان هناك حديث على ان ايران
بدات في الرفع منسوب تقسيم اليورانيوم الى
نسب تتجاوز 60% وهذا ما كان ما حاز على
اهميه كبيره جدا من خلال النقاشات التي
دارت في الاجتماع الاخير لحكام الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الان طهران تقول
بانها توصلت الى تفاهمات والى اقناع
الوكاله الدولي التقنيه ان وجود هذه
الجزيئات هو جزء من عمليه التخصيب التي
تقوم بها طلال على مستوى 60 في المئه
وليست هناك اينيه لايران لرفع مستوى
التخسيب وتجاوز مستوى التخصيب على هذه
المساله اذا يمكن القول بان ما تم الاعلان
عنه اليوم هو محاوله لخفض التصعيد ما بين
ايران والوكاله ادويه على اعتاب الاجتماع
المقبل للوكاله في الاسبوع الاول من
حزيران شكرا جزيلا لك نور الدين من طهران